...putting it on my YouTube channel.
Because usually it's never on YouTube, it's on like, Twitch, but I have to do it for like...
Uh, so like, you guys, okay, so I'm just gonna tell it to my chat now and tell you guys.
So I got like, sponsored by MSI to do a Monster Hunter Wilds launch stream.
And they gave me codes to give away to chat.
And I was supposed to give out some codes today.
So then they were like, oh, you have to do a giveaway.
And then my manager was like, use Nightbot for it.
I was like, I've never done it on YouTube before.
So I was testing it out for today's stream.
And the moment it went live, Nightbot literally deleted my entire chat for spamming it.
Oh, it did that for me too!
During the, what's it called?
The Minecraft tournament thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
Guys, I made, hold on, I made the lobby, but it won't let me invite you guys.
Oh, we have to be public!
No, no, like in the game, like it says invite friends, but it won't let me click on it.
Okay, let's take a look.
Hold on.
I'm also gonna frame rate cap this game because I bet you it's coded spectacularly and it's gonna break something if I don't do that.
I know, I loaded this game up.
It loaded in full resolution, ultra high extreme graphics.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't wait to Zort in like full ultra HD, guys.
I'm so excited to Zort all over.
I've never heard anybody refer to this graphic level as ultra mega, but that's what it's called.
Ultra mega, it's even better than ultra.
That's crazy.
I should tone her down too.
I should tone that down too.
Yeah, it's like, hey, would you like to run this game at ultra settings 4k?
240 frames per second.
And I'm like, no, I'm good.
I'm good.
I was actually, I actually put it on ultra mega because I was, I was, you know, I'm gonna keep it ultra mega.
I'm curious.
I'm curious on how that's gonna go.
I'll keep it on ultra mega, but I'm gonna cap the shit out of the frame rate.
All right.
That's weird.
I won't let you invite people.
Did you figure it out yet?
Me?
Yeah.
No, it's like, here, I can show you like.
There is a lobby.
Well, you just said that no lobbies were found.
Hold on.
This is, this is the way that it booted up for me.
Oh, it didn't actually capture properly.
Just captured my full desktop and I'm gonna leak everything.
Never mind.
Yeah,
all those slurs that I have saved as text files on my desktop.
No, it's literally just your desktop wallpaper.
Like, you're like my favorite words.
All the gamer words.
Damn, don't worry.
She saves it to us all the time off stream.
Is this a scary game?
No, you get to play.
No, it's basketball.
Oh, it is?
Yeah.
There's a cat wearing a Santa hat.
You can play basketball.
That's the only reason why I picked this game.
You can play basketball in this game.
How do you even find these games?
Is, you know, like, I always stalked a popular upcoming on Steam.
And I saw this game before a while back.
And I looked at the reviews.
It had 7,000 reviews.
So I assume it's like, okay.
Maybe if I do return to lobby, I don't know, it seriously won't let me do that.
It says something weird.
Just crash your lobby.
Hold on.
It says host from here if you want to play local with your IP or offline.
Forward port 777 TCP and UDP for other players to join.
What does that even mean?
Your other game's progress will still be saved.
Nah, we got to do this the Minecraft 2008 way, bro.
We got to boot up Hamachi.
Yeah, let me boot up fucking Hamachi.
We're going.
Oh yeah.
We're doing this offline co-op.
So like, clearly you can play online.
Yeah, we just got a port forward.
Right guys?
Wait, hold on.
Let me see.
Oh dang.
I guess you have to play alternate.
That's crazy.
Oh, I figured it out.
Oh, you did?
I did.
I clicked the port.
I didn't click it.
Wait, you actually port forwarded it?
You actually port forwarded it?
Wait, how?
Oh, I can join you.
Nice.
Mint just opening up holes in her router in real time.
Oh my gosh, she opened the port.
We're in her PC, guys.
We're in it.
Oh, there's local audio.
Do we want to use that?
We should use in-game.
Oh, we should do the pro streamer thing where we turn all of our individual things to zero so our foogies will still light up.
That's fair.
Yeah, of course.
You don't have foogies?
Get muted.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to write down what I have on your Discord.
Oh, right.
I didn't actually check that.
That's right.
Mint's at 200.
I'm just going to have to balance everything in real time.
134.
Okay.
Wait, what?
All right.
Wait, how are you guys doing a thing on Discord where your foogies still light up?
We just put ours...
You put...
Yeah, put all of us individually zero.
Oh, you're so smart.
Um, hello?
I gave the idea.
Hello?
I'm just trusting you.
You were trusting us.
I didn't worry about it, doki.
It was collective.
Not collective!
You acknowledged that it was smart!
All right, let me see.
Oh, you can turn each people individually up too on in-game.
Yeah, I was going to say, because you're fucking level.
Okay, let's see.
Turning you guys up.
This is not a group idea.
Am I...
What did you do to me?
That was a piece of pizza.
How do I pick up the boomerang?
Yeah, you can pick up the boomerang.
No, my boomerang!
Pick it up.
Everyone, let me pick it up.
Okay, let me check my volumes.
Oh my god, can you suspend it?
Okay, one...
What?
Oh my god!
I'm trying to do this!
Okay.
Why?
What is that?
What are you doing?
I'm trying to tax here!
That's right.
This is exactly why I play.
I wanted to play this game.
How do you do that?
Wait, how do you...
You press up and then...
Emote.
What's four?
Oh, okay.
That's right.
We're going full sloppy tonight.
Wait, get in front of me, get in front of me!
Oh my god.
I'm looking through the settings and I tab out and I just see a fucking train being ran right through my screen.
Join us, Nuffy!
Join us!
Alt and...
Alt and import.
Import.
Human centipede, this is awful.
I'm zording it right now.
I'm gonna zord all over.
I love this game already, guys.
There's a cat?
Where is he?
He's on the fridge.
There's no individual audio settings.
Where's the fridge?
There are!
There's monster volume and voice chat output volume and that's it.
Don't go into settings.
It's just in like the...
Not the pause menu, but...
Not for people, I want to turn down the sound effects.
Oh, it should be master volume, I think.
Oh my god, you can throw snowballs?
Also, am I loud?
Because I just noticed the thing is like...
My input volume is really high.
I think everybody's done.
Wait, how did you...
Maybe if we go like here?
How about here?
Is that better?
Yeah, that's good.
If it's still loud, let me know.
Because I have plenty of headroom to turn it down.
It's better this way.
Are you doing gotcha?
What is this?
Oh, it's normal or hard mode.
Okay, we should go normal mode.
Wait, there's crouch.
You don't make footsteps when you're crouching.
Wait, guys, guys!
There's a basketball court!
There it is!
Snuffy?
Snuffy's with me.
She's with me.
She's right here.
Is this Snuffy?
Oh, you weren't Snuffy this entire time?
Maybe she crashed.
Wait, did she crash?
Thank you for the three months!
Yeah, I think Intel's striking again.
Wait, where the fuck did Mint go?
Mint crashed?
No, did it go into the lobby?
Did it go into the game already?
No, I don't know where Mint is.
Oh my god.
Wait, let's see.
I'm pointing people down.
Wait, did they all...
Wait, no.
Oh, wait, no, she's here!
She's somewhere here!
Wait, they're hiding!
Where are you guys hiding?
I'm a little scared.
The game definitely just randomly closed, so...
Wait, you guys were in the back this entire time?
Oh my god.
You guys were in the back this entire time.
That's right.
What are we doing, huh?
I'm going to be totally looking for you at all times.
That's right.
I'm going to be scared for you.
Sorry!
These games are scary.
I'm going to have to go through a rigorous testing process.
Were you guys getting sloppy behind the house?
Benchmarking Zort.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
I think you can play basketball in one of the maps.
There's a guitar back there.
Unless you can unlock this later.
This is the end goal.
The end goal is basketball, guys.
That's our end goal.
Right there.
I want a b-ball on the court.
Yeah, I'm here for the b-ball.
Some call me the baller.
I'm actually...
Press to join...
Do you think the more footprints we leave, the more likely it is that Snuffy crashes because it's taking more processing time?
Whose credit card is this?
Oh, I think I dropped mine.
Oh, wait, no.
This is mine.
I got it.
I have somebody's credit card.
So long to no stated says.
I just...
Okay, you're not getting it back then.
No, I want it!
Is that better?
Drop an item, actually.
Alright, are we ready to...
Are we ready to go in?
I don't know.
I got an employee ID.
Don't...
Wait, why do you have two?
I'm gonna leak my employee ID.
I'm leaking it.
That's scary.
It shows like your...
Your code on Steam.
Oh,
they don't see it.
They can't see it because...
Because my fookies are covering it.
Government ID?
Yeah, yeah.
Can't steal my identity now, chat.
Can't steal my identity now.
I've got fookies.
Wait, whose card is this?
Oh, there's no...
Wait, you guys can make snow...
Wait, how do you guys make snow angels?
I'm creeping over to you.
Sorry, wrong one.
I'm sorry, what?
Oh, so cute!
I feel like I'm sliding around.
Can you change my game to Zort, please?
Zort?
Oh, wait.
That looks wrong.
That looks so wrong.
I gotta get out of there.
Oh my god!
Should we try a game then?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, to my sound guys, is the volume better now?
Bomberman?
Bomberman won't snow on the mic.
But not really.
Yeah, that's cute.
Alright guys, ready?
I'm gonna head to the first map.
Zortagane.
Wait, I'm not the host.
Min has to select it.
Nevermind.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, we can buy these?
Oh my god, we gotta buy these!
Oh yeah, just fucking get them all.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I want a flashlight.
I can see a symphony!
Stick
your horn into my snoot.
That's Zort all over.
Okay, Min Min Min, ready to game up.
I feel like I'm an infant.
Alright, I'm ready to Zort all over.
It's Zorting time.
Oh my god, Poppy playtime!
Yeah, thank you for a thousand bits.
Hey, I almost thanked him too, because he looks like he's in my chat.
So I was about to be like, thanks Min.
Thanks for the thousand bits, dude!
I thought I was muting, hold on, let me go find a place to mute.
Chat, I think if you give anything to Limer, it's only fair that you share.
You can't only give things to one child and not the other.
Wait, we don't keep our horns!
We don't keep our horns!
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Wait, what did you do?
I don't know, what did I do?
I don't know, I opened it too.
Oh, we have to hold it!
Oh, Zorto, hey!
Thanks, Zorto!
It turned on the TV.
That's quiet, right?
I hate this channel.
Oh my god, you're right!
Oh, you can see the sound detector of how loud we are.
Dude, I don't like his aura.
Can you do a test with me?
Can you hear me right now?
That's fine, we're not that loud.
Oh, wait, there's flashlights here!
Wait,
isn't that Toa?
Toa on Windows XP?
Yeah, isn't that Toa?
Hello?
Hello, okay, you can hear me now?
Yeah, I can hear you.
Can you mute, hopefully, and then can you hear me?
Yeah.
Not right now, if you're talking right now, I can't hear you.
Alright, let's go!
Grab your flashlights, guys.
Grab your flashlights.
It's right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, where did you get the air horn?
Oh, I got it too!
Somebody's Oshis on the monitor.
No, we'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
Wait, how do we- Oh, we have to use our ID cards here, right?
Yeah.
No, use your ID card.
I think we're like employees here in the Zord Factory.
No findings to eat on the ground.
We're all gonna fucking die.
We gotta be quiet in this area, guys.
Wait, this is a noise-friendly environment.
Yeah.
How dare you tell us to go quiet.
This is a free country.
What's going on?
Zord.
We're here to Zord- Oh, no, I'm ill.
I'm- I saw a man.
I saw- I saw a man.
I don't feel so good.
No, no.
Do you not see him?
He's right there!
You see him, right?
It's a man!
He's right there!
Yeah, I see him!
Is he smiling at you?
Yeah, he's smiling at me.
Do you not see him?
I don't see anything.
There's a man right there!
Maybe I shouldn't be playing here.
There's a hole.
I think she went in the hole and got eaten.
There's a hole!
She's dead.
Don't go in that hole.
There's a hole!
Do you think we need to take her ID card back with us?
Oh my god.
Of course I'm the one that dies first!
Of course it's me.
What the fuck?
Which one's the real?
Why are they all twerking at me?
I don't know.
I think the person is about to get me.
Oh, there's two men!
There's three men!
I gotta go!
I gotta get out of here.
Why me?
Mint is hallucinating men.
No, they don't see it!
The man we see!
Okay, this is a freaky game.
We're in the first fucking room and we're gonna die.
They should all just jump in the hole.
Just jump into the hole.
How did they all not see the hole?
How was I the only one that saw the hole?
That's so fucked up.
That is actually so fucked up.
Of course I'm the only one that sees the hole.
Because I got scared of that man that stared at me.
I didn't see the hole!
I guess we gotta go into the other...
Gamers, don't look down.
Who the fuck looks down?
I've never practiced circles.
I've only practiced triangles and...
Triangles and squares!
What the fuck?
I think I might have just summoned the...
Wait, I'm alive?
What the fuck?
Okay, I thought it was like...
I thought she summoned a chair.
She turned into a chair.
But then I started moving.
I was like, wait, I'm alive.
Like, I think I summoned it.
And then it shows a chair.
And then I was like...
Oh my god.
Wait, I lost my flashlight in the hole.
Oh, I'm not crazy anymore.
I'm not crazy anymore, guys.
I'm not crazy anymore.
Thank fucking god.
I know, I'm not getting...
I'm not going back into...
I don't know.
Wait, is that...
I'm cured, guys.
I'm not crazy anymore.
Wait, wait, wait.
Does this vending machine work?
Wait, oh my god.
No, I got flashlight again.
All you have to do is just jump in the hole.
That's how I got fixed.
You had to...
Okay, maybe she is a monster.
If you jump in the hole, you'll...
You'll get fixed.
Your mental health will be cured.
Yeah, I'll improve your mental health, guys.
Trust me, it worked for me.
Push the button?
Oh, do we leave?
Okay, I'm pushing it.
Well, we haven't collected anything, so we should probably do that first.
I found a chocolate bar.
Wait, is there anything over here?
Well, this is a tutorial.
No, no, no, no, you insta-die.
No, no, no, no, the holes are insta-death.
I'm pretty sure it's like a tutorial.
Yeah, it would be kind of like...
Your friend, Dexter, will not be able to come.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure...
Oh my god, the fuck was that?
Okay, apparently we shouldn't collect gas cans.
What the fuck?
Okay, but what if...
Okay, I got one.
I got one that worked.
Our life is on the line and you're huffing gas.
No, I'm collecting things.
Oh, I think it's like some items are bad.
Let me eat these noodles.
How does it tell me I can google translate this sign?
You are...
Oh, if you have a Rubik's Cube, it will make you sane, apparently.
Wait, we should give that to Min.
No, I'm better now because of the music.
I'm better.
Oh, I see.
Oh, okay, it fills the...
If you hit tab, you can see item information.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I saw that.
There's more gas here.
Fuck your flies.
What's the gas for?
I don't know, it says it'll power stuff up.
I saw a gas can...
Yeah, yeah, that's an evil gas can.
I think it knows that Min's a little crazy.
But like, where do we put the gas can?
I think it's just a tutorial.
Yeah, I think we can just go to the exit, right?
I guess we can leave now, right?
I guess we exit now.
Yeah, I think this is just a tutorial.
This has to be, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, we should all just stand there and see what happens.
Alright.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
Who hasn't pressed the button?
Someone hasn't pressed it.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
What the fuck?
We gotta find Zordy.
Thank you, Zordy.
Okay.
Alright, alright, we gotta find Zordy.
I'm pretty sure Zordy is meant to be like a drill.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure Zordy is the drill.
Oh, it says something opened up.
Oh, they opened up!
It opened up!
Right there.
Oh, yeah, this whole area opened up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Zordy!
Zordy, where are you?
Is that Zordy?
That's Zordy the drill!
We need Jimmy's key.
Hey, we can get a bottle.
Okay, we have to go this way to the right.
Oh, okay.
We gotta go this way.
Note from Jimmy, password equals my high score.
This improves mental health.
What did I just do?
Oh!
Who's he?
Who's this guy?
I think we have a stream sniper.
Who is this?
Wait, he's following me.
Oh, it imprinted me!
Maybe you'll occupy his body if you die.
What is he doing?
It's just a little guy.
Oh, yeah, I just summoned him on accident.
Yeah.
Which one's me?
Why didn't he...
Why didn't he imprint on me?
There's something coming!
There is!
What's our guy doing?
Snuffy, there's something coming!
Wait, is that Snuffy?
He's looking at us!
Oh, he's leaving?
Oh, kind of.
Wait, is that Snuffy?
Is that Snuffy or is this Snuffy?
Remember, you have your guy, right?
Uh...
Are there a bunch of voices in here?
Mint's dead.
What the fuck?!
What the fuck is that?!
Oh, he's carrying him away.
Yeah, I dropped that and they're taking it.
They're taking him.
I feel like this is a fever dream.
Like, what is going on?
I guess we're gonna put him back here.
Oh, wait, this is like Smiling Friends, the big king.
Wait, there's Zordy.
Will this become Mint?
And you shall become Mint.
Oh, there she is!
Mint?
Is this Mint?
Oh, that is not Mint.
Now we have two Zordys.
Yeah,
yeah, the funny thing killed.
Which one's Mint?
Which one is she?
What do I do?
How do I drop him?
Oh, no.
Press G.
No, I want them to follow me.
Wait, there's another one!
We can do this one!
This might be Mint.
This might be her.
I know I have space right now.
I can drop my ID.
I dropped my ID.
Alright, Mint!
Be reborn!
Mint, is this you?
BE REBORN!
Wait, where's my ID?
Is this my ID?
Yeah, this is my ID.
Oh, there's another Rubik's Cube here!
What is it?
What are they saying?
Notes from Jimmy.
Password equals my high score.
Oh, she's back!
She's back!
Oh my God, who is he looking at?
Who is the bunny looking at?
Nope.
Do you think it's me?
Are you fine, Zordy?
Where is Zordy?
What's going on?
I don't know!
I have my own little army.
We need to find like an arcade cabinet or something.
I just feel like I have to do something with...
Oh wait, I have a gas can for it.
I have a gas can.
I have a gas can for the generator.
Where is it?
Yeah, but we need to find the...
What do we do with this thing?
I don't know, but I'm letting them follow me around.
Big king.
Yeah, you want this guy?
You want him?
We need to go find that guy's high score.
Yeah, we need to find his cabinet.
I'm ill again!
Why is everything happening to me?
Hold on, I'll be right back.
Alright, yeah, no problem.
We're like stuck in this...
Do you want a Rubik's Cube?
No, I'm gonna use the music.
Okay.
A new product is on the second floor.
I remember where there was arcade machines.
Oh wait.
Yeah, it's in the lobby.
I feel like...
What was that?
It's fine, don't worry about it.
There's a collectible here.
What the fuck am I gonna do with all of you?
What are you?
What am I gonna do with you guys?
How are we stuck in the first level?
I mean, you could put the Yamaneko back.
Yeah, but like...
But like, what are we gonna do with him?
I am a mom now.
Hello.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I have an idea.
I'm gonna chuck him in the hole.
Bye.
Wait, how did you open this?
There's so many of us.
You pressed the button?
There was a button?
What's this?
Oh, I got a collectible.
Oh yeah, we have five.
Oh, there's Jimmy.
There's a bunny again.
Oh, the bunny.
Wait, she's only after you.
It's only after you.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think the bunny hates...
Yeah, the bunny hates sound.
Yeah, just keep yelling at it.
I'm good at that.
Okay, wait, wait.
What's the high score?
Wait, what game is this?
Okay, I can't see the screen, guys.
I'm trying to get high score.
I got the door open.
Oh, you did?
We're playing video games.
I'm an echo, I'm an echo, I'm an echo.
Oh, creature.
Wait, what's this?
I turned on the PC, guys.
Is everybody okay?
Wild creature is unknown where the creature come from.
There are rumors that it's made from materials in a factory, but this does not comply with the rules of both physics and logic.
Researchers are investigating what caused this.
Okay, it's Zord.
Wait, what's this?
What is this?
Oh, it's more gas cans.
I already have one, though.
What do we do with all these gas cans?
What?
Oh!
Oh my god, I've been holding onto this this entire time.
What?
I didn't do anything.
No, I did.
I think it's already been used.
No.
Where?
I'm worried.
Wait, is that... Who is this guy?
Oh, I have bowling balls!
Yay!
Watch this.
Okay, uh...
Don't look.
Oh, you're not supposed to look at the...
You're not supposed to look at the man.
That man.
How do we get anything for bowling a strike?
Wait, did you get anything?
Yeah, I did.
Wait,
you got the key, right?
Yeah, that's right!
Leave!
That's right!
Wait, wait, wait.
Lime, you got the key, right?
Snuffy has it right now.
The key's here.
Use the key for this.
Yeah, the button.
The second floor button.
Oh, you found my friend?
Jimmy's key.
You should open it.
Okay, hold.
Um...
Uh -oh.
Why?
There's a guy.
Oh, there's a guy.
Wait, wait, wait!
Strike!
She missed!
I got the bully ball!
Don't worry!
I'm a professional.
Wait, where is she?
Where's the cat?
Don't worry, I got bully ball too!
Strike!
I missed.
She didn't like that!
The cat did not like that!
The cat did not like it!
She did not like it!
He didn't like it!
How is this guy in front of me?
Who are you?
Are you an NPC?
Did you save me?
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I got you.
Thank you.
Wait, what happened?
This isn't it.
Who are you?
Are you an NPC?
Were you never real?
We're just bullying the cat!
I've been trying to bully bully the cat!
She'll just end up in the bathroom.
That's just what happens.
Wait, she turned into a Rubik's Cube.
Oh my god, who was that?
Who died?
That's not Fiji, right?
I'm seeing the Matrix, Doki.
I don't think that's good.
We were supposed to turn on...
Wait, we didn't even open the second floor.
I fixed the generator, we need to go open the door now.
I'm losing it.
I need the music.
Don't worry, the cat's too busy with Mint right now.
Alright, I'm pressing it.
I got the door.
Don't worry.
We'll sort our way out of here.
It's just us two.
Hey, what's up?
The moment you entered, I realized it was just us two alive.
Mint did not live.
Oh shit, do you have a noise thingy?
Doki, Doki, Doki!
I have enough, too.
I have Mint.
Don't worry, Mint!
You shall be reborn!
Welcome back, Mint!
Yay!
Okay, I held down that button earlier and it looped and the door didn't open.
I got robbed.
Sure, you did.
I did.
Locked from behind.
Wait, does anyone know the code for this?
I think the code might be go through the window.
8008?
Oh shit, I wrote the wrong boop.
Whoa!
Fake items.
It's not boop, guys.
It wasn't boop.
Yeah, I tried it already.
Does anyone have a bottle?
How do we get sorted?
We can get one from the vending machine.
Maybe we can get a bottle and break the glass.
The glass is already broken.
We just can't jump up.
No, it's not.
Watch this.
Guys, I'm losing it again.
Don't throw it at the cheese.
Wait, what if I throw the bottle at...
Oh, it's fucked up.
Oh my god!
Go rat, go!
Does anyone have a Rubik's cube?
I'm about to fucking die.
Don't worry, we all have seven dollars.
Wait, I opened it.
I did it, guys.
3131 is the code.
3131.
Wait, there's Zoran.
Where'd they come from?
You are ill.
What's this?
3131, the code is 3131.
I said that.
Nobody listened to me.
Thank you.
Oh, jump.
Oh, it taught us how to jump.
Wait, there's an extra Zordy here.
Okay, we need another glass.
What's this?
Wait, there's a Rubik's cube here, though.
No, I saw one.
We need a bottle.
Do you guys have an extra bottle?
Oh, okay, I'm seeing death.
I'm seeing death.
I'm leaving the matrix.
Do you guys have an extra bottle?
We need an extra bottle.
No,
we can keep ordering bottles.
Yeah, we can order bottles for free.
Yes, he's right here.
He's right here.
I told you, I saw a Rubik's cube right here.
It's already solved.
Oh, she solved it?
Too smart.
Alright, let's throw the bottle.
The ill effects are really annoying.
Are you sure Doki didn't die?
Doki, are you dead?
I'm right here.
I mean, Doki is...
Doki is dead for me, I don't know.
Doki is a skinwalker.
I just read a thing about that.
Wait, what did it say?
What?
Wait, who's that over there?
Wait, why is there two...
Where did he come from?
What
about this glass?
Maybe we have to try this glass.
Wait, who's who?
I can't tell.
There's too many of us.
How are you all seeing people?
There's so many!
Where are they coming from?
Where are they spawning?
I don't know where they're spawning from!
Guys, I actually bought a flashlight.
I'm pretty sure we have to wait for players.
What the fuck?
Wait!
What the...
They fight back!
They fight...
One of them shit me!
Yeah, they're skinwalkers.
They're skinwalkers.
I thought you died.
They hit me!
I'm climbing!
Let's go!
There's no way.
I have Zordy.
You have Zordy?
Can you find a Rubik's Cube?
I'm stuck!
I can't move!
Why can't I move?
It won't let me pass!
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
I'm not a skinwalker.
I'm real.
I'm pushing it.
Why is there more Zordys?
Are we supposed to push it through here?
Maybe all of us together.
Yeah, I'm number three.
I see something.
I don't know how to activate this.
Wait, what about this?
It says we need a saw.
Oh, I have food!
I have food!
Guys, I can't see anything.
I don't know where I am.
Guys, guys, guys!
Here's food!
Take the food.
It restores sanity.
I need food.
Okay, that didn't work for you, I guess.
I think Min is stuck in the vents, guys.
How do we do this?
I don't think we can.
I think they're just here for...
What?
We're trying to figure out how to get back up top!
How do we get back up top, too?
Wait, no, the saw is right here, guys!
The saw is in here!
Min, just stay in here for a bit!
We're doing something important!
Don't worry, we'll come for you later!
Don't worry, we'll come for you later, Min!
What is she saying?
Alright, activate the zort!
It's zorting time!
Alright, don't worry, Min!
I got the flashlight!
Where are you?
Hello?
I don't think she's okay.
Don't worry!
Zorts can't climb!
Is everything okay?
Oh, we did it!
Don't worry, we'll fix it later.
We gotta take the zorty to the elevator!
Wait, there's bullet balls in there!
He's stuck!
Oh, he's after me!
He's after me!
Please!
Get him off!
He's stuck!
Just get him off!
I'm in the back rooms!
Oh no, I'm in the back rooms!
Oh no!
Not the back rooms!
Where am I?
Oh, where am I?
I don't like this.
Oh no, I'm lost.
Where am I?
I'm already lost in the back rooms!
I just started!
What?
Oh, there's a door here.
Hello?
Hey guys!
Hey, I'm back!
It's like nothing bad happened to me.
Where's everybody else?
Why is it just us two?
What happened?
What happened in the back rooms?
I was in the back rooms!
Yeah!
It took me to the back rooms!
Where did our Zordy go?
Please, please, I can't go back!
I can't go back to the back rooms!
Please!
Please, I can't!
Take her and not me!
Take her!
Oh no!
We have to win together as a team!
As a team!
I don't want to go back to the back rooms!
I don't want to go back!
Please!
I don't want to go back to the back rooms!
We did it!
I'm gonna take her stuff.
Is this someone?
I don't fucking know anymore, dude.
I know, I know!
I know!
I'm trying to get shanked by this guy.
Thank you!
It's the same fucking hall!
Oh my god!
GG!
How did I die?
I died to the same hall!
How did that happen?
I don't want to be triggering those dolls!
We were so close to the end!
We can do this again!
I don't know why!
We made eyes through!
I didn't die first!
We know how to play!
We know now, we speedrun!
We know now!
You gotta pick it!
You gotta be the one to pick it!
I think we have to finish it to unlock it, though.
I'm ready!
I'm so ready!
All of us can skip, yeah!
Someone's not skipping it!
Snuffy!
Alright, let's go!
Let's mid-max!
Oh, we have to turn this on first.
Alright, mid-max time!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm ready to zort!
I'm zorting!
I'm ready!
Open the door!
I'm zorting!
Open it!
There we go!
I think for that, yeah!
I think it's so to like...
So like the skinwalk...
It's to convince us...
For skinwalkers.
Oh no!
Come on, everyone!
We gotta press the button!
Wait, we're missing one.
We're missing one.
No, she's not dead because it's waiting for other players.
Oh, there she is!
Nice, alright.
Now we go this way.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna grab money.
I got a Rubik's Cube too.
Yeah, there's more here.
No, no, no, you just have to press E.
Alright.
Someone asked like...
Wait, is the Jimmy High score the same one?
It's different?
I got gas cans too.
I'm gonna play it.
I'm gonna play Bomberman.
I'm playing Bomberman.
Nice.
I lost.
Okay.
And then...
Where's the key?
Alright, let's go, let's go.
Wait, get BoomBall ready!
Or he's gonna start zording.
Okay, I'm gonna stay at the generator.
I have a gas can for it.
Pew-pew, pew-pew.
I got it.
Oh, no.
Don't look.
Alright,
I'm gonna head over.
I'm running.
Why don't you?!
Oh, no.
There's so many.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Wait, where's Snuffy?
Snuffy?
Um...
Where did Snuffy go?
Where are they?
Oh, why are they all crazy?
Wait, wait.
Is that...
He's not real.
That's not a real zord, is he?
Is that those...
Maybe one of them, um...
One of them could be the real snorty, right?
One of you guys are Snuffy, right?
Is one of you Snuffy?
If you're the real Snuffy, please stand up!
Please stand up!
Literally, one of you has to be...
Oh, they're all dead.
Snuffy?
He's in here.
Where did she go?
Snuffy?
Snuffy's hiding somewhere.
But where is she hiding?
Snuffy?
No!
Please don't bring me back to the backgrounds!
Please!
Hello?
Snuffy?
Snuffy, where are you?
Where did you go?
Where have you been?
Did you go on an adventure?
Where did you go, Snuffy?
We were worried about you.
Okay, I'm bringing Mint back.
Snuffy?
Mint, you're back.
Welcome back, Mint.
Welcome back.
That was so good.
Where was Snuffy?
Oh, come on.
The guy was chasing me.
Really?
If you don't want to get hit, he won't get you.
Yeah.
If you crouch, he literally just looks like standing next to you.
I can't.
Shut the fuck up.
I can't see the glass, okay?
Don't shoot!
I hit myself!
I don't understand.
I give up.
Someone else do this.
You're not very good at throwing stuff.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
What was that, huh?
I literally did it the first time.
I'm just saying, you know.
I had a concussion.
You can't blame me.
Very good.
There's a man in front of me.
Snuffy!
I'm the dependable type.
What is it?
What's the code?
I'm loading the data.
Nine, okay.
Nine, eight.
Alright, let's go.
I'm gonna rubix my cube a little bit.
I don't have a flashlight.
Someone else does this.
Oh, there's another imposter, dude.
Why are they a thing?
Damn it, there's a guy right there.
Let's see.
Got a flashlight.
Let's go.
I'm heading over.
I'm coming over.
Hello?
Testing, testing.
Jump down, jump down.
Oh, there it is.
Being in the color yellow.
Why can't I?
How can the imposter do it, but I can't?
What makes you different?
It's like deep inside the bin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's right here.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Okay, now I'm gonna saw it.
I don't know who's real.
Who are you?
Do you have like a therapeutic kind of toy to play with?
Okay, we all have the...
Do you want one?
Yeah.
It's gonna start coming upstairs.
Do we have bowling balls?
Do we have bowling balls on us?
I don't know how true that is.
I have a bottle.
I have a bottle just in case.
I'm gonna get more bottles.
We need weapons, we need weapons.
That big guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bottles are free, remember.
Yeah, bottles are free, just hit him on the ground.
Have him ready.
There he is.
I hit him, but it did nothing.
No!
Please!
Why didn't anyone hit him?
No!
I don't wanna go back!
Please!
I
don't...
What the fuck?
Why didn't no one do anything?
No!
Why did you all watch?
Why?
This is so fucked up.
Why did you all just watch?
Why did you all watch?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Does she live?
No, she is alive!
Wait, but we saved a lot of dolls!
We saved a lot of dolls!
So she can pick up a doll.
Oh my god, wait!
I don't know, I didn't read.
I didn't read.
We didn't study.
So many dolls, she should be able to find one.
Where is the doll?
Oh, she is fucked.
She missed!
Deserved!
We are gonna be stuck in level 1!
Why didn't you guys warn me before?
I thought we were gonna throw bottles at it!
Also, I need to cut freeload back into the lobby.
Because the sound is fucked up on my end.
Why?
We are back.
Oh my god.
The sound is like, extra fucked up for me.
Oh wait, I didn't mean to.
I meant to react.
Can I join?
Oh, I can.
Invite me back, please.
I need to wait for invite.
I can't believe it.
I wanted them to throw bottles at it.
I wasn't ready.
Invite me.
Where is my invite?
What the fuck?
Wait.
Someone invite me back.
I forgot to say invite me back.
No!
They have to remake the server.
They can't invite me back.
I'm gonna restart my game then.
I'm gonna restart my game.
That sound was so fucked up when I died.
When I was in the back rooms.
The sound was so fucked up.
Is the sound a lot better?
Apparently, my sound...
People try to tell me that the sound was pretty fucked up.
But I hope it improved.
The monster destroyed the sound.
Yeah.
I just don't wanna go back to the back rooms.
I just don't wanna go back.
Don't let me go back.
Please.
I can't go back.
I'm back!
When you go to the back rooms, they fuck up your sound.
Yeah.
You don't wanna go to the back rooms.
It's a very scary time.
I don't wanna go back.
There might be people loading in now.
I'm ready.
Ready?
How does it feel like we've been playing this for 15 hours?
Only an hour has passed by the way.
Only an hour.
And we're still stuck in level 1.
We know how to...
Stupid fucking...
I hate Zort.
Fuck Zort.
Don't press...
Guys, press H.
Guys, press A.
Wait, how did you do that?
How did you do that?
Oh, press E.
Are you a skinwalker?
Is that you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm in.
Come on, let's go, let's go, let's go.
We speedrun, we speedrun.
We can do this this time.
I believe in us.
I'm grabbing coins.
I'm waiting for players.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Wait, who are we missing?
We're missing one person.
Alright, we did it.
Man.
I saw...
I saw him.
Alright, things should be okay now.
Alright, I opened.
It's not the same arcade, right?
No.
No, no Jimmy.
I do this one over here.
Not this one.
Nope.
It has to be this one, right?
No?
Or maybe this one.
Oh, 49601.
49601.
Alright, nice.
I got another Rubik's Cube.
Does anyone have a gas can?
Who has a gas can?
Alright, pick one up.
Pick one up.
Alright, someone...
Someone press the button.
Hello.
I'm safe.
Snuffy's still alive.
Which one is the real Snuffy?
Um...
Oh...
What's happened?
Is Snuffy missing again?
Yeah, Snuffy's missing.
Hey.
Keep your piles closed.
Spawn faxes didn't die.
Oh, don't worry.
We did too.
Don't worry.
We also watched Mint get horribly murdered.
Why did I just die?
What just happened?
How did I just die?
I have a concussion!
She died twice.
She died because the rabbit came over and then the rabbit jumped at her instead of me.
Wait, which one's the skinwalker?
Is it this one?
Which one?
Is that him?
That's fucking right.
You're in the wrong neighborhood, buddy.
That's right.
You're in the fucking wrong neighborhood.
Get out of here.
Wait, how did you trigger it?
How did you trigger the skinwalker?
98.
Yeah, idiot.
Alright, I'm ready.
Wait, there's another one!
Oh my god, there's 20 of them!
Get out of here!
Get out!
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
I'm in.
I hid it.
He seemed fine.
He didn't eat me.
Yeah, I don't even know how to jump.
Okay, I'm gonna grab the saw.
I grabbed the saw.
I have the saw on me.
Oh,
I wasn't the one that died to the cat.
I'm helping.
There we go.
Bye, bunny.
Off to the back rooms you go!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, Jesus!
What's this?
What's
this?
Who are you?
Stuffy, is this you?
Get over here!
That's not real.
Oh, that's real.
No, no, no.
We're all real.
This is me, Stuffy, and I'm...
I'm gonna try and get a plushie.
I'm gonna atone for my sins.
There's a dude there.
I'm sorry.
I'm atoning for my sins.
Mint, is that you?
That's so funny.
Why would you do that?
I revived you!
What did I do wrong?
What did I do?
Come on, let's go help.
It's right behind us.
Man's behind me.
What?
Saw a man.
Don't look at it, I think.
Oh, they're after them.
Wait, that's not...
That's not... I don't know.
I don't know who that is.
Oh, there's...
No?
I don't think so.
There's no way.
Wait, everybody's dead.
We should stay together.
Wait, where are you?
Hello?
Please no, not again.
Not again.
Oh, not again.
No, I'm not looking at binary codes right now.
Oh no.
Not the binary codes!
Please!
I'm working so hard!
Just push the drill!
Push the drill!
I'm looking at binary codes!
I don't want to go back!
Oh my god.
Please!
I'm looping him!
Oh god.
I don't want to go back.
Don't make me go back.
Oh my god, I'm gaming right now!
Not the numbers!
Money.
Oh please.
Please!
I've been stuck on the table!
Oh my god!
The room is disintegrating!
I'm going crazy!
I can't see!
I'm looking at Zord for too long!
Oh no.
Oh no!
It's all unstable!
I'm going mentally ill!
Oh my god.
I don't think I'm supposed to look at Zord for this long.
No!
Oh no!
This is not good!
This is not looking good for me!
Where did he go?
I can't see anything anymore!
What happened?
No!
Not again!
I went crazy!
I went...
What happened?
Did he escape?
Who's who?
Where is everybody?
I'm so confused!
Who's who?
I don't know!
Oh no!
I just got back!
What's...
What's going on?
I have gas can!
Where did I put it?
I got it!
What else do we need?
Oh no!
Oh my god!
I'm so dead!
How many vtubers does it take to start a car?
Oh my god!
Alright, I clutched that Zord round!
I had Zord chasing me the entire time while you pushed that drill!
I saw binary numbers!
He was putting numbers on my screen, guys!
We did it!
We Zorded out!
We Zorded out of here!
I would say I was the best bait out there.
We did it, guys!
We actually finished episode 1!
It only took us 3 tries, guys!
It only took us 3 tries!
But we did it, guys!
I just wanna play basketball!
I just...
I just wanna...
Is this the basketball level now?
Maybe!
Episode 2 might be basketball level!
Oh!
Oh, there we go!
Road trip!
I owe you my life!
Whoa!
There's 4 of us, though!
Here in the woods?
Damn!
Oh, we ran out of gas!
I'm the one on...
I'm the one in the van!
Oh?
Oh my god, Herbie?
Is that you?
This is...
Oh?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Guys, we gotta run!
We gotta run!
We got a car chasing after us!
Guys, we gotta run!
We gotta run!
We got a car chasing after us!
Oh my...
Wait, I think he ran over...
Which way do we go?
Okay, it's just you and I!
It's just you and me!
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Oh!
Oh god!
The car took Snuffy a minute!
Oh my god, it's just us two!
We gotta go to Yonkat!
Don't worry, we can make it!
Don't look back!
Okay, he's so far.
Look at him.
Look at him, look at that.
Whoa, what you gonna do?
He drove through!
Oh, he can't drive through!
Where do I go?
I'm not Snuffy, it's Donkey!
Am I dead?
Wait, what happened?
What?
What happened?
I think Snuffy crashed.
Oh!
I touched the stone and it was like waiting for players and then nothing happened.
I ran out of the way of the car and then it ran me over somehow, I don't...
I saw a hole and then I...
One hole in that area and then I...
I jumped into the hole and I died.
It was glowing!
No, it was different!
It was different.
The hole was glowing, guys.
It was so different.
Oh, I can only invite her to watch VBridger.
Oh my god, no!
Wait, can you not invite her?
Let me see if it's like...
Can you do it, Donkey?
Because it's registering me as only playing VBridger.
It says no lobbies for her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And also she's like a pure...
I think she's invisible, right?
How's the sound then?
I don't know if I should up the volume a little more or not.
I just wanna play b-ball.
When do we get b-ball?
When do we get basketball, guys?
Is their mic okay?
Or should it be louder?
Wait, I can't...
Oh, it invited me again.
Louder?
Were they that quiet before?
Or was it just now?
Wait, why can't I get in?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna restart my game.
Alright.
Alright, I'll boot up my game.
I need another invite.
Game is being weird.
I might have to...
I might have to go non-invisible.
Game details.
Friends only.
There we go.
I just wanna know...
I just wanna know when...
Oh, everyone has been quiet for a while.
Sound guy!
No!
I can't seem to join.
I'll boost him up a bit then.
Okay.
I have been banned from Dave and Busters.
I went non-invisible too.
But yeah, I'm not getting invited too.
Wait, where's Mint?
Oh, Mint.
Reboot.
Reboot the game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mint is showing as VTS.
Alright.
Yeah, sometimes, I think when I'm in the back rooms...
It like, makes the sound super weird.
Yeah, the audio bugs.
I boosted everybody up higher though.
Just to hope that works.
Yeah, now she's zording.
Okay, now that Mint is zording...
We should be able to get her in.
She's zording now.
Yeah!
I hate the back rooms so much.
I hate it.
Let me know if the sound gets better in this new one.
I'm here.
Yeah?
I always wanted a brother.
Just like you.
We're harmonizing.
Beautiful.
There's new stuff to get in here.
Yeah, let's surround where Snuffy will be with the...
Have you found that the directional audio is sometimes really weird?
Yeah.
Sometimes it's like...
When you get really close and it'll be like, no, you can't hear them.
When you get in the back rooms...
It like, fucks up your audio.
And everybody sounds like they're in like...
You're in like a hole somewhere.
I think it was Snuffy went to the back rooms.
Oh, hey, Snuffy's here.
Praise be to Snuffy.
Alright, are you guys ready to get eaten by a car?
Yeah.
I turned my graphics into potato mode.
I'm ready.
Let's do it.
Alright, let's go.
Bum, bum, bum.
Okay, we all touch a rock.
Touch the rock.
Don't go into any holes, guys.
There's a hole that can kill you.
Alright, I skipped.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No!
There's three of us!
Yeah, I wonder if it's the car level.
Yeah, yeah, maybe we'll see.
Okay, still left.
Go to the left.
Min, are you still alive?
She's still alive.
It's fine.
Yeah, we got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We know the exact way.
Don't worry, the car is really slow.
Woo!
Bum, bum, bum.
Touch the rock!
Touching rock!
Run where?
Oh, here!
Oh, not the hole!
We did it!
Okay, let's see if we can invite her.
Should we try to re-invite Snuffy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's try to re-invite Snuffy.
No!
Wait, it says invite friends here.
Oh, wait, no.
Oh, no.
I don't think she can do car level.
Unless, like...
Unless she can turn her graphics even harder.
Even further back.
There's no going back.
There's no going further than potato.
No!
There's the basketball court!
Me too!
Okay, no, no, it's fine.
No, no, we try again.
We try the car level again.
So we can get her in.
Should we try one more time?
Yeah, let's try one more time.
Yeah, the running part's not very long, too.
Hello?
Who's that?
Oh, it's a shop!
Oh, it is!
Oh!
What's this?
There's a fist.
Where did he go?
What just happened?
I don't know.
He just...
He exploded!
Okay, guys, we have to go back to the main menu and invite Snuffy back.
I have to play ball.
We do.
I gotta be ball.
Okay, alright, Snuffy.
Bye, car.
Bye, everyone!
Return to lobby!
We need the ball.
Alright, invite Snuffy.
Game is not paused for real?
Yeah, you can't pause in a multiplayer.
Yeah.
We might have to restart the lobby.
It's so finicky.
I don't know.
I must play b-ball!
Let me play!
That's all I want!
All I wanna do is play basketball!
We will b-ball!
I'm back.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What are you doing to me?
Lay down in bed!
Join us!
What was that?
You know what to do.
Stop it, man!
Stop it!
You're ruining it!
Snuffy!
Snuffy in the corner!
Snuffy, go stand up beside the bed.
Like in the corner.
Snuffy just likes to watch.
He's got the chair.
Snuffy in the corner!
This is what sorting is all about, guys.
This is what sorting is all about.
This will throw off the skinwalkers.
Yeah!
Skinwalkers don't got we got.
That's right.
This time, we got the car.
We got the car, Snuffy.
Be careful until it crashes.
What if Snuffy hoes next time?
Maybe if Snuffy hoes.
Oh, that's true.
Alright.
Oh, there's four of us.
There's four of us in here.
I see four of us in the car.
Oh, no.
She's still there.
I see her.
Keep talking, Snuffy.
Keep talking so we know you're alive.
Oh, my God.
We get people!
Let's go.
We're gonna Minecraft with the Youngscast.
To the right, to the right, to the right.
To the right, to the right, to the left.
To the left.
Just follow us.
Let us know if you're still alive.
Touch the stone, touch the stone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't go into any holes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do we all touch it?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, my God.
How did you figure that out?
I would've died horribly so many times.
Oh, here we go.
We made it.
Oh, my God.
We get people!
Guys.
We can play basketball.
Don't worry.
I'm here for the most important game of all.
Did you guys know?
That I'm the baller?
That's right.
No!
She's gone.
I missed it.
We just made it!
No way!
I'll miss her.
We just made it, too!
That's right.
I missed.
I don't know the...
Guys, it's been a while, guys.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck, guys?
It's been a while.
Yeah.
What?
Don't give me my ball back.
No, no, no.
Is that storm getting closer?
Is it the storm that is approaching?
Wait, there he is.
Wait!
How did you get it in?
Wait a minute!
Okay.
The basketball, baby!
That's right.
I scored on my own basket, but that's okay.
I was testing something out.
That's right.
What does the button do?
Wait, what?
How did you steal it?
No!
Oh, my God.
Back to defense.
I'm going to do a three-pointer.
Watch this.
Okay, I...
Did you just hear a scream of agony?
No, I'm playing meatball.
Okay.
How is the...
What is the power meter?
I'm getting cooked right now.
I don't know the power meter of this fucking...
of this fucking basketball.
Okay.
Watch this.
This is going to be the shot of the century.
Oh, my God.
I did it.
I'm doing it again.
I'm doing it.
Guys, I'm figuring it out.
I'm so sad.
All I wanted to do was play meatball.
I'm winning.
I'm doing it.
Guys.
Yeah, go fund me for Snuffy's meatball PC so we can play basketball.
Go fund me so we can play basketball with Snuffy.
Here, I'm passing it to you.
Catch.
That's right.
And I'm going to steal it.
How are you faster than me?
Dirt.
Take that.
Whoa.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Defense.
Wait, what's his name?
This guy.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
There's a lot of things in this game where there seems to be no point.
Like basketball.
I love you, Snuffy, listening to us from behind.
Snuffy, we miss you.
Snuffy.
Go fund me for Snuffy's PC, guys.
It's such a beautiful night for Snuffy.
Snuffy.
Come back, Snuffy.
Okay.
We're ending the moment there.
We miss you, Snuffy.
Let's go back to the lobby, guys.
Let's go back to the lobby.
We can't do this without her.
I think we have to finish.
People were saying you can B-ball in the lobby, but I think you have to beat episode 2 to unlock the basketball court.
Yeah.
Alright, Snuffy.
The moment your PC is fixed, we're all coming back here for basketball.
I'm gonna watch.
Do it.
Don't be a pussy.
Wait.
Before you do it, you should grab a basketball.
Oh, never mind.
Yeah, I think you have to move off.
Oh,
my God.
They turned Min into a Rubik's Cube.
Funniest shit ever.
Guys, I'm gonna steal her identity now.
Guys, I'm gonna dox her a Steam ID.
Is it actually a Steam ID?
Yeah, it would be a shame if I show her a Steam ID right now.
Oh, hey, you're back.
He's back.
Oh, he went into the background.
Yeah, it's kind of awkward.
Oh, here he comes.
Don't touch it and see what happens.
Yeah, what does he do?
Hey, buddy.
Aww, he's cute.
What if he's actually a horrible betrayer?
Skinwalker.
There's a Skinwalker.
That could be Snuffy.
It's not Snuffy.
Snuffy, I'm gonna take you to the back.
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
Get out of here.
Get out.
You should push him onto a mine or something.
There's a mine on the other side of the basketball court.
Oh, is there?
Yeah.
It's over this way.
Alright.
Come follow me, me, me, me.
Me!
Why does the Mimic have a...
have a flashlight?
It's because he's smarter than us.
Wait, is this a trampoline?
Yes.
Is this...
Are you real?
Yeah, I'm real.
Oh, wait, is it...
Oh, yeah.
Alright, don't worry.
Wait, he died.
Oh, he died.
What even is in this house, anyway?
What's in here?
Oh.
I mean, there's nothing weird about this house.
This house looks perfectly safe.
Just a lot of mines.
This house is so safe.
Like, nothing to worry about at all.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, my God.
I'm a musical genius.
Oh.
Wait, what happened?
What?
No, I was gonna show...
I was gonna show you guys a guitar!
I'm sad.
The game zorded me out.
I rocked too hard.
The music was too good.
I found a guitar!
I was gonna jam!
And then the lobby disappeared!
I was gonna rock out!
Where's Stuffy?
Is she rebooting her PC right now?
She got zorded out.
I think she should close Discord.
So, I was playing Henry Stickmin the other day...
and there was like a weird glitch...
where it...
where it, like...
kept breaking the game if I had Discord open.
Oh, that's weird.
I mean, we're gonna be...
Oh, wait, you caught it.
Wait, I can catch it?
Oh, I can.
Alright, 2v2 basketball.
See you in the courts.
Wait, turn around?
You fucker.
I think she left.
I don't know.
Wait, she's not streaming anymore?
Is she not streaming?
She said she could try one more time...
and I was like 3 minutes late to seeing that message...
so she might have just given up.
No!
At least she's still alive.
One last ride, Snuffy!
One last ride!
They locked up the basketball court.
I can't believe it.
Oh, she's done?
She saw my message...
so she's coming.
I went and creeped on her stream.
I heard her.
Come back.
Let's make a shrine for her.
Yeah, right here.
She's gonna spawn right here.
I believe in her.
Snuffy, we're all here for you.
Snuffy, praise be!
Praise be!
We're here to Zort.
Zort!
The Snuffy!
The almighty Snuffy!
Wait, did you send an invite to her?
I sent her a couple, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Oh, dude!
If you turn the camera down, there's a really weird crotch seam on the model.
I don't see it.
No?
It's like a melded seam.
I don't see it.
Oh, I see my ass.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, do you see his ass?
It's like ribbed.
Whoa!
That's what I mean!
I was not expecting...
I was not expecting Zort to be...
To be packing up there.
Or down there.
Damn, no wonder he does this.
Wait, let me see.
Praise be!
Hello!
Hi!
Hello, I have come back.
Welcome back!
We were so close to b-ball!
I know.
Okay, I'm completely naked now.
This is my last resort.
Okay.
I believe.
Zorting in the nude, let's go!
That's how our parents did it.
Alright, skip time.
We're skipping, we're skipping.
Alright.
Snuffy, are you still here?
We're running, we're running, we're running.
Snuffy's just gonna have to make noise constantly so we know.
So we know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll be like, Snuffy live check!
Snuffy live check!
Jump!
Mic check 1, 2, 3!
I'm jumping and I'm jumping!
I missed my...
Guys!
I did not make it.
I did not make it to the bathroom.
She probably went to the bathroom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was an intentional fall.
Touch it, touch it, touch it, touch it, touch it!
I'm running!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Uh, surely I'm gonna live through this.
How did...
How did I get into another hole?
How do I...
How did I...
How did I get to another hole?
Oh my god!
I'm back!
Let's go!
It's time to B-Ball!
Oh my...
Praise B!
Alright, teams, let's...
Let's get in the teams, everybody!
Alright!
Skins and shirts.
Okay, we can't tell.
Who are you?
Okay, this is...
Okay, um...
I don't know how we tell who's who.
Oh, what the fuck?
Hey, hey, hey!
Who are you?
Who's this?
Okay, okay.
I'm part of your team!
This is me!
I'm jumping!
Don't let him steal this!
No!
How could you let me just take that from you?
I got it!
Oh my god!
No!
We were so close!
I dribbled past her!
Yeah!
Even the little ball is mourning.
Me!
Yeah, I know, little guy!
We will...
Guys, go fund me for Snuffy's PC so we can B-ball.
Alright.
She would want this, guys.
Guys, she would want this.
She would want this.
She wants us to twerk on her?
Yes, she would want this.
Right?
Good morning!
Good morning, Snuffy!
For Snuffy!
Snuffy!
We're doing it for you, Snuffy!
What the fuck?
There's two of them now!
There's another ball!
Snuffy!
I'm expecting these things to explode or something.
We could just twerk until we die.
We're basically Kesho.
We're just partying until we die.
That's a party over there.
At least they're all so sad for her, too.
I hope she knows that we're twerking for her in memoriam.
In memoriam, Snuffy.
2025 to 2025.
We're going out in style.
Let's all stand in the mines and die for her.
And then we'll call it there.
It was nice.
3, 2, 1...
Why is it always me?
Hello?
Why is it always me in the back rooms?
Why is it always me?
Hello?
Oh, are you in the back rooms?
What?
Back at it again.
You leave and then maybe it'll trigger it.
3...
She's back in the back.
How'd she get in?
That was the weirdest back rooms I've ever been in.
They really do act so realistic, don't they?
They act just like me.
I'm guessing Lime died and left.
Yeah, she did.
No, no, I'm alive, I'm alive.
I'm gonna be the only one here.
Mint, the last remaining twerker.
I ain't gonna lie, but I don't think it gets to actually kill one person per explosion.
Does it actually?
No, no, I got killed too.
But I got sent to the back rooms.
Oh.
Yeah, it's just Mint was too far off.
Only one person needs to...
I will refrain until we can all play together.
I will refrain.
Return to lobby.
Snuffy should get back here so we can just say goodbye together.
Do you think Snuffy can come back and just say goodbye?
We'll do the second one when Snuffy fixes her computer.
Yeah, yeah.
I believe...
Wait, there's a cat up here.
Yeah, we saw a cat in the beginning.
For Snuffy, guys.
For Snuffy.
Goodbye, Snuffy.
Don't worry, we'll be back when your PC is fixed.
Bye, guys.
Bye, bye.
It was fun.
Bye.
That was fun.
It's sad that Snuffy's PC crashed.
Oh, I'm still in.
I'm still here.
I guess she's still in here, too.
Oh, man.
That sucks, though.
I don't know what it is about the b-ball.
I guess the b-ball map was too high-res.
That's all.
That's all I could think about.
The b-ball map was just too much.
There was just too much balling going on there.
Yeah, but whenever Snuffy's PC is fixed, we'll definitely try it.
We'll definitely do a part two of this game.
It was really fun, though.
It was really fun.
It's just unfortunate that her PC couldn't handle it in the end.
But I hope in the future we can play part two again.
But, yeah.
Also, the stream's not ending because I'm here to give away some Monster Hunter codes!
I don't know if I can do the nightbot thing.
I'm gonna see if I can do the nightbot thing because that was awkward.
Nightbot started timing out every- It timed out 206 people when we- Jesus Christ.
It timed out 206 people.
Oh my go- I'm sorry.
I am so sorry.
I'm gonna turn things off.
Okay.
It's because of excessive symbols and- Okay.
I think it should be okay now.
I'm inviting nightbot back in if anybody wants to test it out.
Nightbot is now back in, so it should be okay now.
I think.
Alright.
I hope so.
Disabled, disabled, disabled.
Alright.
I think it should be okay.
I - Alright.
So!
I was given several codes for the Monster Hunter Wilds launch and a huge shoutout to MSI for sponsoring Monster Hunter Wilds launch.
Monster Hunter- Capcom actually sent me a package too, like creator package.
By the way, I was very surprised at both the sponsor and the creator package because um, uh, because the last time I played Monster Hunter was the 2007 Monster Hunter PSP game.
So I was not expecting myself to like you know, get sponsored by to like to do anything Monster Hunter related.
So, very huge shoutout and uh, thank you to um, basically to Monster Hunter for um, oh there's a reason why.
Okay, required level.
Let's see, uh, let's do like everyone.
I'll update it to everyone, see if that works.
Uh, alright.
Can you guys do the- use the command now?
Does anyone fucking know?
I don't know how to use nightbot apparently.
Uh, it says it's online.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
Okay, let me.
Alright, now it's spamming.
Okay, show advance or cool down.
A hundred sixty seconds.
Guys!
Guys, stop!
We're trying to figure this out!
Okay, I have to use nightbot.
Okay, okay, there you go.
I made the cooldown.
Okay, alright.
Everything should be okay now.
Now, now nightbot, don't stop.
Guys, everything is okay.
Alright, so so I have to do a giveaway for uh, okay so it's gonna be a keyword giveaway.
Alright, so the keyword- what is the keyword?
I didn't set up the keyword so I don't remember.
Uh, the keyword is- Alright, guys.
To enter the giveaway for a code, a free code for the game Monster Hunter Wilds it is let's see exclamation point, enter.
Alright, so to enter the- let me get the white color here too.
Guys.
Alright.
If you wanna enter for a chance to win a code- free copy of the game you do this.
It's exclamation point, enter.
And then you just enter it once.
You don't have to spam it.
You just have to enter it once guys.
I need to look at how many codes I'm giving away too.
I'm a professional.
I was supposed to do this tomorrow but I'm not doing a stream tomorrow so, um because I'm not doing a stream tomorrow, I'm doing it today instead and I believe it is wait, this is not- this is the 28th I'll also be giving away codes on the 27th as well on the day it launches so I'm just gonna let you guys know that I'll be doing it twice.
One for today and then the other for the other for on launch date itself.
So I believe it's 5 codes today and then 5 codes on the 27th.
Let me grab the codes real quick too.
Let me let me let me let me grab- let me grab the stuff real quick.
I need to make sure I need to make sure I'm doing this correctly cause like my manager's asleep right now so I'm like am I doing this right?
my mod was briefed about this mod.
Is it 5 codes today?
I lost stuff to do guys.
I have a I didn't know if my moderator was briefed.
It would be funny if my moderator was like, I don't know let me check real quick mods, do you know if it was 5 today?
Guys, I lost stuff to do guys.
I need to be sure if it was 5 today or in 5 on the 27th or if it's 10 today.
Okay, yes 5 today.
Okay, cool.
Alright, guys.
I have 10 codes.
And then I'm gonna pick the win- I'm gonna see who the winner is at.
Wait, how do we send the codes to them?
Wait a minute.
Oh, that's awkward.
How do we give them the codes?
Like We'll figure this out.
Alright, we have 477 entries.
Alright, we're gonna pick the first winner.
Brush!
Congratulations, Brush!
You won the first one!
Alright, type a message Brush so I know you exist.
Brush, if you type a message, give us your Twitter- Give us your Twitter handle too, by the way.
We're just gonna DM you the Twitter.
We're just gonna DM you the- On Twitter, we'll DM you the code.
Because like- Yeah, you!
Yeah, me!
Yeah, you!
What's your Twitter handle, Brush?
What is it?
What's your Twitter handle?
If you don't have one, make a Twitter and then it'll- Guys, okay.
We'll just make sure we can DM you your Twitter handle.
Or email.
What's your email?
We need your Twitter- Either your Twitter handle or your email.
Oh, shit.
Okay, guys.
Don't spam him.
If he puts his email down, do not spam his email.
Do not spam his email.
I don't know.
I wanted to just randomly post the codes but like, obviously that doesn't work.
So like- Oh, add!
Okay, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna put that in for my mod.
Please don't.
Okay, give us your Twitter handle.
Twitter handle is like the safest.
Okay, I think like my manager did not- I didn't think this through and cause like I thought I was just putting my codes down but they wanted an actual giveaway but then I realized wait, this is a lot harder if we're on YouTube cause we can't whisper things on YouTube.
Cause in Twitch, if you do Twitch giveaways, you can whisper people on Twitch to give them the codes.
And then I realized how the fuck am I gonna give them the code?
Alright, yeah!
Either give us your Twitch handle give us your Twitch handle or your Twitter handle.
Alright, Simon, I got it.
I got it.
Here you go.
That's his Twitter handle.
Okay, enter.
Okay, let's see.
If you win, give us your at for Twitter or your Twitch account.
There we go.
We're figuring this out.
Guys, we're figuring this out.
We're gonna figure this out live on stream.
Alright, there you go.
Alright.
Our first winner.
Alright, second winner.
Sai166 Congratulations!
Type in chat.
If you're live, type in chat.
If you're still here.
Type in chat.
I can see them waiting for messages.
I can hide.
Oh, he's alive.
Okay, what is your Twitter and Twitch handle?
What is your Twitter or Twitch handle?
So then we can DM you your code.
Okay, that's a hello.
Hi.
Okay.
Oh shit, sorry.
Whoops.
That was not what I wanted to do.
Enter for monster hunter wilds game code.
There we go.
So people who are like, the fuck is going on?
Alright, what is it?
What is it, buddy?
We're still waiting.
I'm still waiting for him to tell me his handle.
I'm still I'm still waiting.
Are you making a Twitter account or Twitch account right now?
Is that what you're doing?
Is that actually what you're doing?
Like...
I don't know if he's making it.
Alright, buddy.
If you're making a Twitter or Twitch account right now, I'm gonna give you like, I need a note.
Give me like 5 seconds.
I'm gonna give you 10 seconds to tell me if you are.
10... 9...
8...
7... 6...
5... Bro, he's not saying anything.
I think he is making his account, guys.
He's not saying anything!
I'm like asking if he...
This is all he said to me!
He literally was just like, hi.
Like, are you even... Are you real?
Are you a real person?
I can't tell.
This is all he said.
Ever since he got... He won.
I don't know if this guy is a real person.
He has said nothing since.
This is literally all he said.
He has said nothing since!
Oh my...
Like, that's all...
That's all he did.
Bro, I'm sorry, man.
I'm gonna...
Oh, wait.
Oh, he's here.
I'm here.
Okay, okay.
He said, okay.
What's your Twitter?
What's going on?
What's going on, buddy?
We need your skinwalker.
Alright.
Okay.
What is your Twitter ad or your Twitch account?
Are you making your account right now?
We need to know.
If you are...
If you are making either accounts right now, I'm gonna...
I need to know.
So, we go on to the next person.
We can go...
We can go on to... Alright.
Okay.
Mines.
Just pay attention if Psy166 ever...
ever shows up again because I'm gonna pick the next one right now.
Alright.
Congratulations!
You won the third account!
The third one!
The third code!
Congratulations!
Is he gonna say anything?
Are you alive?
Hello?
Is he around?
Wanyunma!
Are you alive?
Waiting for messages.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
Are you in the room with us right now?
I don't know if he is.
At them in chat?
I don't know if I... Okay.
Let's see.
Give us a sign.
Say anything!
Like anything at all!
We just need to know if you're alive!
Alright.
If he doesn't claim the reward in like 5... in like 10 seconds I'm pulling another one.
10... 9...
8...
7... 6...
5...
4...
3... 2...
I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm sorry.
We're re-rolling.
Alright.
BoxyBrown!
Are you in the room with us?
Can I get BoxyBrown in chat?
BoxyBrown?
Are you alive?
Buddy...
You can't just enter and leave.
What the fuck?
You can't just...
Why did everybody just enter and leave?
Where did they all go?
I wasn't even...
I didn't even do this for that long!
BoxyBrown!
Just say one...
Type one letter.
One letter!
Guys!
You don't even...
Just one letter and then also...
I just didn't know if you were alive.
I didn't...
They got taken.
Oh my god.
They're all just gone!
Five codes.
There you go.
Then you know it's...
Okay, I'm gonna give them 10 seconds.
10...
9...
8...
7...
6...
5...
4...
3...
2...
1...
Goodbye, BoxyBrown.
I'm sorry, BoxyBrown.
Alright, Bayron Aros!
Oh my god, like I don't even recognize these names.
Like, so many lurkers has came out for it.
Alright, Bayron Aros!
I feel like a substitute teacher right now.
Bayron Aros!
Do we...
Do we have a Bayron Aros in class right now?
Oh my god.
Do we have a Bayron Aros?
Oh, he's alive!
Oh my god, finally!
Oh my god.
We actually have a response.
Alright, our third code.
Our third code.
What is your Twitter handle?
A real person.
Oh my god, an actual real person.
What is your Twitter handle or your Twitch account?
We need to know so we can whisper you the code.
He's real, guys.
He's actually real.
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom while he types that out.
I'll give him extra time to type out his account info.
I'll be right back, everybody.
Don't put your email!
I realized email was a bad idea.
But like, we're figuring this out as we go on.
We got a Bayron for sure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be right back, everybody.
All Bayron said was, hey.
So like, I don't know.
Bayron!
Are you still with us?
All he said- Oh!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I got it.
Bayron126.
Bayron126, write this down!
Write this down.
Oh my god.
We're doing it, guys.
We're figuring this out.
Alright.
Fourth code.
Sonic3167!
Are you in here with us?
Is he present?
Sonic13167.
Are you here in this room right now, Sonic?
Are you here in this room?
Please.
I need- Oh, he's here!
He's here!
Oh my god.
Congratulations, Sonic.
I hope you have fun with Monster Hunter.
I hope- Alright.
You know the drill.
What is your Twitter at twitch handle?
Oh my god.
He's here and he's alive.
No problem, Sonic.
I'm so excited to see Sonic play Monster- Didn't, like, Monster Hunter do a collab with Sonic the Hedgehog before?
I feel like they did.
I feel like Monster Hunter did a collab with Sega.
Right?
Did they?
I don't know.
Right?
They did, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They did.
Oh, I remember that.
Alright, what is your- Oh, there it is!
There's a Twitter handle!
Miss M- Alright, write that down!
Write that down!
That's the other guy.
That's- Thanks everyone.
Sonic, we need a Twitter handle.
You can say thank you later.
This is for the side guy.
Sonic!
God, Sonic, you can thank people later!
We just- We can-
Celebrate - Celebrate later, guys!
We- Celebrate later!
No, the one Yoon guy never responded.
So, like, I'm just re-rolling.
The one Yoon guy never responded, so the next roll is the last one.
He's being- We celebrate.
But yes, this is not the last code giveaway.
We are doing another giveaway.
Another giveaway on launch date, so five more codes will be given out.
A huge shoutout to MSI.
MSI is the one that provided all these codes for us.
I actually have an extra code because Capcom also gave me an extra code, but I'm reusing the MSI code because, like, you know, they gave me a code first.
And a huge shoutout to MSI.
They're promoting one of their newer monitors, so please feel free to check out the link that's being sent by Nightbot right now regarding the monitors and stuff.
Alright, Sonic.
We just need your handle.
Sonic, we just need that and then we should be good to go.
This is so scuffed, but, like, do you- Do you really expect something different from me?
Yes, thank you, MSI.
Alright, this is their handle.
There it is.
Alright, last roll.
Are you guys ready?
The last person getting a code.
Hey, guys!
Congratulations!
Congratulations on the last code!
Hey, guys!
Are you still here?
Are you still here, though?
Hey, I recognize that name.
Let's go!
Oh my god, we all know that guy.
Alright, hey, guys.
What is your Twitter slash Twitch handle?
At DokiBird.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, alright.
Alright, is that your final answer?
Because I will just reroll your raffle.
What is your Twitter slash Twitch handle?
His name is Lily.
He said to me!
We did it!
Go stir so I can win.
Damn, that's wild.
Is it this one?
Alright, one of your Dragoons doxed you.
Alright, nice.
Is that- yeah, alright.
Your Dragoon doxed you so you don't have to tell me what it is.
Alright, nice.
Alright, congratulations everyone!
Congratulations everyone who has won!
Um, I- Okay, by the way, speaking of giveaway codes, okay, so if you guys follow me on Twitter, I was talking about, um, Cheating Cheetahs, the- the stupid, um, FPS game where everybody aimbots, and then, you know like, the game was actually made by a Japanese game company,
and they like, reached out to me in DMs and was like, oh my god, thank you for promoting our game.
Um, we wanna give you some free game codes for you and your fans.
And I was like, yay, I love free stuff!
So like, I guess- I guess in the future, I'll also be giving away game codes for that game too.
I don't know when, I don't even know when that game comes out, I just thought it was so fucking funny, so I like, quote retweeted it.
Um, anyway, so, I'll be giving away game codes for that too, but yes, huge shout out to MSI and Monster Hunter for reaching out to me to help do this giveaway, and also like, sending me a creator package.
I really appreciate it, please check out the MSI monitors, uh, this is not really- I know that I was supposed to do this tomorrow, but then like, I don't have an actual public stream tomorrow, it's gonna be a member stream tomorrow, so that's why I'm doing this today.
Uh, but yes, anyway, there's also gonna be another, uh, there's gonna be an announcement tomorrow on Twitter for something, but uh, you'll know when you see it, it's gonna be on Twitter, but you'll know if you see it.
Um, so yeah, other than that, I'm trying to take it easy, but then I was screaming a lot today, because like, I don't know, I was pretty fucked up today.
Um, but I'm gonna try and take it easy.
Uh, Fudge Shop, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, thanks for the awesome stream, Doki, it was so nice meeting you in the meet and greet last weekend, please remember to send, okay, bye Fudge Top, I require DNA test.
Uh, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here everybody, as always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing, and if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody, bye guys, bye!